ça donne quoi
combien de temps
promis ça va falloir repasser pour la
subtilité
[Musique]
vous en savez plus sur cette fille né
dans l'ouest de l'Inde où est-ce qu'elle
se trouve actuellement nous essayons de
la localiser mais pour l'instant rien il
y a quelque chose qui va pas
change de réussite 85 %
[Musique]
je t'avais dit que c'était pas un jeu
soit pas mauvais perdante je vais
m'occuper de toi
pour qui
[Musique]
lorsque les gouvernements échouent le
dernier recours c'est la charte les
agents les mieux entraînés qui
travaillent ensemble pour maintenir la
paix dans un monde chaotique
je vous envoie à Lisbonne
le cœur donne à la charte son pouvoir sa
modélisation est tellement précise qu'il
peut provoquer le crash d'un avion
il peut prédire l'avenir
le cœur dit que tu n'as que 32% de
chance de
récession d'en face la charte existe
pour une sonnerie pour sauver le plus de
vie possible les chiffres ont parlé
obésité
il y a quelque chose qui va pas
j'espère que tu sais ce que tu fais
[Musique]
je contrôle la situation tant mieux
pour Stone faut vraiment qu'on discute
je suis légèrement occupé là
[Applaudissements]
on risque d'être pas mal secoué
dans trois
[Musique]
tu es qui sans déconner on s'accroche
sérieux tu es qui
Stone
qui tape
je vais m'occuper de toi